hello everyone and welcome to game eight
of the world chess championship match
2021 we are in the second half of the
world championship so seven games
already been played seven more to go uh
and the magnus is leading the match uh
he won game six game seven was a very
uh well sort of a calm calm draw and now
we have game eight will nipple try to
strike back with the black pieces or
will he try uh you know to
have a nice calm game then have a rest
today and then maybe try and come back
with the white piece so this uh game is
what it is i'm not gonna talk all that
much about it before we actually check
it out for those of you who still don't
know what happened uh as usual we have
some nice photos to check out let's uh
see the the handshake so there we have
it uh magnus was again uh late to the to
the party uh you can see that nepal was
already sitting he stands up they uh
have a nice handshake so
no fist bumping or or anything and no
eye contact if you remember in that game
six we had um we had a very impressive
eye contact before the game and that
game definitely delivered uh here we
have uh the the first move being made by
michael salgado of uh real madrid i'm
told he no longer plays for them but
that he was uh well a very good player
he played e4 for magnus not sure if he
asked him whether he wants to play e4 or
not but um
he he did play magnus did say something
maybe he said play e4 maybe he said you
know play play whatever we want i'm good
with anything
and uh well that the the pawn actually
remained on the board so that being said
let's check it out e4 was made magnus
doesn't uh you know retract or anything
he just hits the clock and nipple
replies with e5 so we'll see if we'll
have a repetition or will we see
something else we have knight to f3 by
magnus and nepo repeats knight to f6 he
goes for the petrov defense like he did
uh in that game four uh and in game four
magnus played knight captures on e5
which is a very nice reply but here he
goes for the more aggressive d4 this is
the steinitz attack uh and it can lead
to some very interesting lines and the
the the most common way to play this is
to just capture but not e captures on d4
this is also played knight captures and
e4 is considered the absolute best line
for for black so here bishop to d3
we have d5 defending the knight and only
now magnus recaptures his pawn with
knights to d7
and the magnus grabs at knight captures
bishop captures and now there are a
couple of very interesting moves that
you can play here such as castles knight
to c3 but magnus plays knight the d2
it's uh
not a new move or anything it's been
played
many times but it's uh not easy to deal
with if you if you don't know how to
play it and if you uh encounter it in a
wheelchair champion to match so there
are a couple of nice ways to meet it uh
the the most um uh well
impressive one for black seems to be f5
but this looks like an ugly move to play
if you don't know it's the it's the main
move and you know it kind of weakens
your king so maybe it's uh it's not an
easy move to play another thing if
you're not sure maybe you just go back
with the knight knight to f6 and then we
see something like castles bishop to d6
and white continues with c4 and it's a
nice game for both white and black but
nepo makes a very interesting choice he
actually captures on d2
which kind of help helps magnus develop
we have bishop on it you notice uh that
there are no knights left in the game so
there will be no horsing around this
game uh and bishop the d6 by nepo again
uh trying to go very very symmetrically
symmetrical here uh queen to e7 is
always a popular choice here you really
ask white what are you planning are you
trading queens or not and if something
like bishop to e3 we can even go into
the forcing queen to be for check and
now after queen to d2 just trading
queens captures captures and you play
the same game but did you know after
that uh torture in game six it doesn't
seem like this is something you want to
do against magnus already on on movie
11. so nepo continues developing he
plays bishop to b6 and now this is
looking very very aggressive look at the
two mighty bishop pairs it's not very
often that you see something like this
so here magnus castles and he's asking
nipple are you also castling here
because if you are we're going to have a
very interesting game if you cancel i'm
playing queen to h5 threatening
checkmate it looks barbaric but it works
very nicely and then after f5 preventing
this uh who knows what might happen
bishop g5 we attack the queen let's say
bishop b8 we offer a queen trade queen
h4 now queen d7 sort of
we get some sort of a position like this
where black will have to figure out what
to do with the light square bishop and
the white will have a very uh reasonable
way of
developing his pieces maybe even f4 can
be played at some point so this is uh
what magnus is offering after castles
but nipple says nope we're not going to
have that i'm going to play h5 and h5
is not only a very impressive move it's
a movie nipple made after some 20
minutes of thinking it's also a new
movie it was never played before and
once you see it it makes sense so you
prevent the queen from going to h5 uh
ever again
another thing white castle black did not
castle just yet so if we see something
like g3 h4 already threatens to open up
the h file so magnus really has to
figure out how to go about
at this position and he does magnus
spend here some almost 40 minutes that's
insane to spend on one move uh in a
world championship match but it it is
required because
what do you play here so your usual
suspects are something like c4 and queen
to f3 but it's not easy deciding on
either of them after a move like h5 it's
just a
pretty crazy move to show you at least a
little bit for example if c4 which is a
move you usually play uh queen h4 and
now if g3 we can even play queen
captures on d4 that's the reason if
bishop c3 yes we're gonna win back our
pawn queen to g4 we offer a queen trade
now we trade let's say captures captures
bishop captures and g7 rook g8 and now
we're gonna throw in one check after
king to d7 we go back bishop to c3 and
we get this position where white can't
really say that he's enjoying it all
that much uh you know uh black will get
rid of this pawn he will uh push the the
f pawn as well and it doesn't look like
all that much for for white another
thing you might consider uh after this
h5 move is just going queen to f3 uh
looks uh you know very interesting you
put pressure on the uh d5 pawn
but then after bishop to e6 as you are
expecting rook to e1 so the bishop is
well placed there we might see something
like for example bishop f4 queen to f6
now putting pressure
extreme that white queen and now let's
say bishop to b5 check c6 and now bishop
captures and d6 some trades will happen
captures uh first we're going to capture
this with check
we want to win back our pawn b captures
for example g captures on f3 and you
would have this position where it's uh
six pawns against seven but uh magnus
would have the double death pawn and uh
it's uh probably playable both
both pairs of rooks are still in the
game and it's uh you know bishops are of
opposite colors but again it doesn't uh
give you all that much so it's just uh
too complicated of a position to really
decide where you want to go because any
move you play here can you know uh
leave you with a train of thought that
will last for maybe like an hour which
it did in this uh particular case as
magnus spent some 40 minutes in this
position and he decided on queen to e1
check not even rook to e1 check because
after rook t1 you know what nipple is
playing after rook t1 chip
czech
and then you know it's a it's a complete
madness of a position something that uh
uh well nipple actually thrives in so
magnus instead went queen to e1 check
not rook to e1
and now we have king to f8 so like the
honey badger uh nepo just doesn't care
and he he doesn't want to uh you know
worry himself with how he's going to
castle or anything because if you play
bishop to e6 now now it's a it's
different the queen is on the file and
you can start pushing the f pawn so now
the rook and the f file in the queen and
the e file that definitely uh make a
difference so king to f8
not worrying about castling and now
bishop to b4 also one of the reasons the
queen is nicely placed on e1
to guard that bishop on b4 we have queen
to e7 offering a queen trade but also
threatening bishop captures on b4 and
now magnus plays bishop captures on d6
now you can't really trade queens
because you're going to have to
recapture on d6 with the pawn so queen
captures on d6 this leaves the queens
into the game and now queen to d2 we
have to develop our queen to get the
rooks into the game and now
again how do you continue here you might
continue with h4 this is always very
nice if you can get that h3 move in it's
going to be it's going to be great so
magnus will probably play something like
h3
but nepo just starts by bringing the
rook into the game and magnus does the
same rook eight to e1 to counter the the
rook on e8 uh and then now rook to h6 uh
preparing to bring the rook maybe maybe
to f8 to put some pressure to f6 to put
some pressure on the white king's
position uh but also you could just
trade for example captures captures and
then rook to h6 if you want to remove a
pair of rooks off the board uh nipple
seems uh
at the thing that that's not necessary
he goes rook to h6 right away and now
queen to g5 by magnus putting again
some pressure on the position and it's
not easy for for nipple to make a move
but it's not all that difficult either
he just plays c6 here he says all right
i'm going to defend my d5 pawn and what
do you play here well okay magnus plays
rook captures on e8 it's uh the the the
absolute best move because the king can
capture you lose the g7 pawn so you have
to play bishop captures and now comes
rook to e1
and now we have this position where
carlson's bishop is very nicely placed
the queen is very nicely placed and the
rook is very nicely placed where the
bishop on e8 not all that much so here
we have queen to f6 uh offering to trade
queens but uh of course we do not want
that we just go back queen to e3 and now
magnus is threatening queen to e8
checkmate so of course we have to tend
to that so bishop to d7 now the bishop
nicely covers the light squares queen
and king cover the d7 square so nothing
to worry about here and we have h3 by
magnus at some point you will move the
rook move the queen so any additional
square for the king will be much
appreciated and now nipple has to decide
how to go about this position whether he
wants to play h4 whether he wants to
start maybe with g5
also seems like a possibility the bishop
here that seems to be not doing all that
much could actually
give support for that g for push at some
point
but nipple starts with h4 first
it's a good start because you can still
play g5 g4 the h4 pawn only you know uh
improves that if you've seen any uh you
know neural nets uh playing chess you
know that pushing that uh
h or a pawn can can go a long way and
the situation on the clock here is if
you guys are interested 41 minute for
magnus and an hour and 12 minutes for
nipples so magnus really uh
spent a lot of time deciphering that h5
idea that nipple played uh and here
again you can play many things uh you
could just play c3 which is kind of you
know
it looks a bit uh boring equalish but it
does make sense but magnus decides to go
for c for right away so putting pressure
under the d5 pawn uh but even uh this
doesn't uh doesn't appear to be all that
much so nipple can still consider a move
like g5 uh but he doesn't he plays d
captures on c4 we have bishop captures
on c4 and now again uh it's a it's a
pretty crazy position now the bishop is
a bit stronger than he was on d3 a move
to consider here is definitely uh king
the g8 because well this bishop is here
it's fine it's guarding the e8 square
but if it disappears queen to e8 will
still be checkmate so king the g8 is
just a nice safety precaution but nepo
played b5 here uh you know it's it's a
very nice move attacking the bishop here
you know you can start advancing the a
pawn next but the problem is
this is a bit of a blunder so for those
of you who haven't seen the game uh feel
free to pause the video here and find
the refutation of this b5 move while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations uh uh on figuring out
this triangle and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is it is
of course queen to a3 and then when you
see this then everything makes sense
yeah that's right queen to a3 check this
is what magnus played uh and uh well we
did not see a lot of uh nipple on the
board after this move was played because
this is a problem this pawn now hangs
and it doesn't matter that your bishop
is attacked because here the if you play
something like queen to d6 if you block
we play queen captures an a7 and we
guard the d4 pawn but it also doesn't
matter if the bishop is captured because
queen to a8 check and you're getting
checkmated that's the real issue
wherever you play the the bishop doesn't
really matter queen or rook captures
will be checkmate so this is a huge
problem and nipple can't just play
something like this so he played king
the g8 but this also doesn't uh
help him all that much here magnus just
played queen captures on a7
and uh well it's a it's a it's a very
difficult spot to be in here you can see
uh magnus uh sitting at the board uh
after he he played this there's no uh
young
anywhere to be found even though it's
his move he was uh probably somewhere in
the bathroom trying to compose himself
you know trying to uh work uh his uh
mind around the fact that he just
blundered a pawn in a world chess
championship match which is you know not
easy it's not easy you know if you're
playing in a in in a bar tournament you
know if you blunder upon you're you're a
little bit upset but if you if you do it
in a wheelchair championship match it's
just uh i i of course i can't imagine
what it feels like but i i can i can
imagine it's it doesn't feel pleasant uh
and here uh it's uh time to make a
decision how do you want to continue
here can you really compose yourself and
try to find a way to to stay in the game
because well it's not just that you're
down a pawn it's it's also you just
blundered and your position is is bad uh
for for one b3 and a4 create a pass pawn
for white and it's going to be an
incredibly strong pass pawn
but that's what it that's basically what
it means to be to be a champion and here
you are challenging the champion and you
you have to be able to compose yourself
and uh you know try and uh uh figure out
how to continue here that's what we
would see if magnus was in this position
and if the roles were reversed
and
how you do this is by playing bishop
captures on h3 uh it doesn't give you
much but it might give you a fighting
chance uh point is that you can't really
capture the bishop if you capture the
bishop then it's just terrible b
captures on c4 and now it's black who's
actually better you open up the white
king and
not much for white to show for however
after this move white would have the
incredible queen captures on f7 queen
captures and now rook the e8 with check
of course it cannot be captured as the
uh the the attack the bishop is uh is
creating this um
beautiful uh pin so king the h7 has to
be played now bishop captures an f7 and
after this bishop moves as it is
attacked let's say bishop to f5 we're
going to play some lego bishop g8 check
he goes here we're going to go back here
and enjoy this position being up upon
but still uh black will have fighting
chances uh is it it's not impossible for
for magnus to make a mistake however
after queen captures an a7 nipple in
back queen to d8 uh sort of preparing
rook to d8 to put some pressure on the
d4 pawn to at least win something but
now magnus just moves his bishop bishop
to b3 and it's not going to be easy rook
to d6 was played but how are you ever
getting this bishop away from d7 look at
this bishop attacking f7 the queen
attacking f7 the rook can also be lifted
let's say rookie three rookie four to
help out with with the attack against
the f7 square and this is the absolute
strongest idea recommended by all the
engines and this is what magnus plays so
not uh not an easy time for nepo
and it's not easy to find the move you
could just maybe repeat some rook g6
rook f6 but even this will not be enough
magnus will just play queen to c5 and
now what's what's your move the h4 pawn
is now hanging even that and if you move
now even rook to e7 is an idea now it's
an even nastier uh threat uh so after
rook to e4 nepal played bishop to e6 he
decides to go into the end game now
uh but uh here it will it will be a
one that is uh much more unpleasant than
the one we discussed if bishop captures
an h3 was played so here bishop captures
an e6 we have rook captures on e6 rook
captures f captures and now uh queen to
c5 it is one of the moves that actually
win this position but uh
magnus plays it the the problem is yes
it's a queen and a queen and pawn end
game and those are the most difficult
end games in chess if you ever tried
learning about them you know from a book
on end games you you know how
complicated they are but magnus knows
that
there are three things that make this
position winnable for white one of them
is uh he's able to create a pass pawn
with b3 and a4 another one is that these
pawns are incredibly weak so black will
have uh you know very very difficult
time defending them and the third one is
the weak king and g8 you can see that
the white king is very safe on g1 the
black king is wide open so those three
things combined make this uh
position you know
impossible to defend for black so here
we have queen the a5 by nepo it is uh
again uh not a very resilient way to
play this and now the position is
completely winning even though he's kind
of threatening queen to e1 with queen
captures on f2 but for the second time
feel free to pause the video and win
this game for magnus while i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this move
it is not an easy move to find and uh
although b4 is a very impressive move in
this position no it is not b for this
time it is actually queen captures on c6
so congratulations to everyone who uh
figured out that this is okay and you
can allow black to do this as this seems
to be the only way to win this uh game
for white so here we have queen to e1
check king the h2 nipple captures on f2
but now queen captures an e6 with check
we have king to h7 and now queen to e4
another check before we secure all of
the squares because the one thing you
don't want to allow uh
is something like uh uh well let's say
the queen is not defending d1 square
let's say you allow queen g3 check when
you want to check when g3 check queen
you want check you have a perpetual and
you will no longer be able to win this
game so magnus needs to take care of
that we have kinked the g8 and now
magnus is down to some 15 minutes on the
clock nipple has some 24 minutes on the
clock uh but it doesn't matter uh magnus
uh spent some time here plays b3 and he
shows that there is no way to to
actually play this uh no you could play
b for now capturing here of course is
met with just queen captures uh e8 with
a queen t check uh followed by capturing
on b5 and defending this pawn but even
b4 now you can just start pushing d5 and
after let's say queen captures on a2 uh
the pass pawn is much too strong you can
even capture on b3 d7 and that's it
after one check let's take into g1 queen
to c7 we're going to guard this square
but queen to d5 check next move we bring
the queen into the game and it's game
over so nipple actually had to go for
the other line that we've shown that it
doesn't promise all that much queen to
e8 with cher king to h7 and now queen
captures on b5 so the pawn is now nicely
defended queen f2 nippo is still
dreaming of some sort of a perpetual but
now queen to e5 just regarding all of
the squares not allowing anything uh we
have queen to b2 attacking the pawn now
queen e4 check came to g8 and now queen
to d3 everything is nicely defended and
after queen to f2
magnus plays queen to c3
uh we have queen to f4 check king to g1
move 40 has been reached so no more time
pressure for for either of them king to
h7 and now queen to d3 with check g6 by
nipple and now magnus even brings his
queen to d1 saying that now everything
is protected and there is absolutely
nothing you can do here i'm just gonna
start pushing my d-pawn and that's it
that's game over so queen to e3 check
was played king to h1 and now nepo is
without a move magnus played this uh
basically to perfection every move was
the absolute top engine move uh g5 he
wants to try something like g4 maybe h3
then trying to open up the the position
to start giving some checks but magnus
just plays d5 that we have g4 magnus
captures on g for we have h3 and here
magnus plays queen to f3 and he was in
this position animal 46 that ian pondich
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here uh even if you open
up uh the position with captures this uh
the the i mean it's you're up three
pawns of course this is unplayable uh
you can even be you know completely
uh bold and and go you know up the board
with your king doesn't really matter
it's a queen d2 queen king the e5 check
queen to g5 check now you block queen to
f5 check of course you trade the queens
but
regardless of what black plays you will
you will always be able to uh you know
get out of checks and then uh promote
one of the pawns to a queen so of course
after queen to f3 nepal depleted all of
his uh resources uh and he had to resign
uh this game so uh magnus wins not only
game six he wins also game eight and now
nipple is a really really bad position
eight games have already been played so
we're gonna play an additional six games
uh and uh nepal now needs to win not one
but two games to get back into the match
so now i don't think we'll be seeing uh
the the same approach as we've been
seeing so far uh this is uh well this is
a pretty pretty tough situation for
nepal to be in but maybe it's a great
situation for the for the match and for
us the viewers because now uh i believe
the games are about to get a lot more
interesting of course we're not going to
see overpushing or anything because that
would be just silly uh but who knows we
might see the marshall attack we might
see some uh other you know crazy ideas
because he has to come back into the
match somehow otherwise uh you know he
okay he can just draw the other six
games and play you know incredible chess
but uh
um it's much more likely that he will
try to get back into the game will be he
be able to compose himself he does have
a rest day will he you know come back
stronger from all of this uh we'll see
but uh you know it's it's uh well it's
been a long time since uh magnus
won two classical games uh
in a world championship match in the
actual classical portion
so yeah
that's the game i hope you guys uh
enjoyed it uh nipple most definitely
didn't it's i mean blundering upon in a
world chess championship magic game
that's
you know i would not like to experience
that i mean even though it would mean i
would actually get to play there but
still it would it would be uh too
difficult to to you know to handle uh so
we'll see uh what happens but yeah once
again i hope you guys enjoyed this i
would like to thank ak-47 anika
chubinitsa pretty much lorenzo kevin
huang and christopher hall for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
world church championship
with game 9 and we'll see if jan will be
able to bounce back with the white
pieces thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day